[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit niki
7 schönen guten abend ihnen allen
gemeinsam im studio mit mir ist jeder
kristin otto ritten sport sehr gern
einen guten abend und das sind unsere
themen an diesem montag
historisches gesetz der senat stimmt für
das größte sozial und klimapaket der us
geschichte trotz abstrichen ein sieg für
präsident biden
rauswurf vorerst abgewendet eine
schiedskommission entscheidet altkanzler
schröder darf trotz seiner kreml nähe in
der spd bleiben
und vorkehrung für den corona
herbstsonntag erwartet in den nächsten
wochen die zulassung eines angepassten
impfstoffs
die letzten monate waren nicht unbedingt
erfolgreich für us-präsident beiden
seine partei zerstritten und vor der
wichtigen kongresswahlen im herbst
liegen die umfragewerte im keller
gestern nun brachten seine demokraten
ein historisches reformpaket durch den
senat dass die klimapolitik der usa
nachhaltig ändern könnte es war musste
beiden erhebliche abstriche machen wurde
auch von der eigenen partei nicht
verschont trotzdem ein erfolg wie el
mati wissen berichtet
letzten sommer brauste joe biden eigens
im elektro hammer herum um werbung für
seinen rettungsplan fürs klima zu machen
nun verschafft die stimme von
vizepräsident in kerbela harris dem
neuen gesetz eine hauchdünne mehrheit
es ist massiv klein gemahlen aber immer
noch historisch
heute nach einem jahr harter arbeit
schreibt der senat geschichte
ich bin sicher dass dies einmal als eine
der grössten gesetzgebungen des
einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts gelten
wird
370 milliarden dollar allein zur
förderung von wind und solar technologie
steuerfreibeträge für endverbraucher die
auf erneuerbare umsteigen milliarden für
den bau von fabriken für batterien und
e-autos die größte investition in
saubere energien in der us geschichte
mit weltweiter signalwirkung
wir können in china indien und andere
nicht zum mitmachen bewegen wenn wir
selbst nichts tun das ist nun ein sich
anders mit positiven folgen für den
globalen klima kampf
das gesetz soll außerdem auch die kosten
im gesundheitswesen senken preise für
medikamente drücken zuschüsse für die
krankenversicherung erhalten trotzdem
verweigerten alle republikaner ihre
zustimmung denn die gesamtausgaben des
pakets von 430 milliarden dollar werden
durch eine mindeststeuer für
umsatzstarke konzerne gegenfinanziert
joe biden plan ist nun zwar mächtig
geschrumpft aber er sieht es als sieg
für das ganze land das ist eine große
sache es wird das leben der menschen
verändern es dauert ein wenig bis es
wirkung entfaltet aber alles ist gut
mit höchster wahrscheinlichkeit wird
auch das repräsentantenhaus am ende der
woche dem gesetz noch zustimmen
die waffenruhe im nahen osten scheint zu
halten israel hat nach dreitägigen
kämpfen gegen die militante
palästinenserorganisation islamischer
jihad seine grenzübergänge zum
gazastreifen wieder geöffnet
im palästinensergebiet konnten schulen
geschäfte und behörden wieder aufmachen
nach angaben der dort regierenden hamas
wurden bei luftangriffen neun wohnhäuser
zerstört und rund
1.500 wohnungen beschädigt 44 menschen
seien ums leben gekommen
viel wurde zuletzt über ex-kanzler und
gas lobbyist gerhard schröder
geschrieben und gesprochen seine
anhaltende loyalität zu wladimir putin
auch nach dem völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg erschütterte nicht nur
große teile der gesellschaft und der
opposition sondern auch die eigene
partei
sozialdemokraten fordern einen
parteiausschluss eine spd
schiedskommission in hannover entschied
heute dagegen kristina eglseder
während die landtagswahlen in
niedersachsen ihre schatten bereits
voraus werfen liegt über diesen spd
ortsverein in hannover ein schatten den
die genossen gern loswerden er mitglied
gerhard schröder er macht jetzt sein
eigenes ding auf eigene rechnung
hat mit der partei nicht mehr viel zu
tun was ein russischer gasunternehmen
sprachrohr seines freundlich putin mit
seinem verhalten so der vorwurf schade
er der spd die juristische bewertung der
schiedskommission heute in hannover wohl
eine enttäuschung für die 17
antragsteller aus ganz deutschland kein
verstoß gegen die partei ordnung der
antrag später stehe mit seinen
äußerungen nicht so weit außerhalb der
programmatik und der grundsätze der spd
dass die partei diese nicht mehr
ertragen müsste und der bereich der
persönlichen freundschaftsbeziehungen
gehöre zum höchst persönlichen bereich
der lebensgestaltung der alt kanzler und
sein anwalt sehen sich damit bestätigt
für mich ist wichtig dass vielleicht
in unserem lande es wieder möglich wird
auch andere positionen zu vertreten und
mich solche nebenkriegsschauplätze
aufgemacht werden trotz des freispruchs
von der bundes-spd heute deutliche worte
der distanz für uns steht fest so lars
klingbeil politisch ist gerhard schröder
mit seinen positionen in der spd
isoliert das prominenteste mitglied des
ortsvereins hannover in ungnade gefallen
seinen mitgliedsbeitrag spenden sie hier
ganz bewusst für die ukraine
fragen wir nach im zdf hauptstadtstudio
bei theo koll theo welche bedeutung hat
dieser schiedsspruch für die bundes-spd
und ihren umgang mit gerd schröder und
ich glaube dieser schiedsspruch ist wie
die aussicht auf einen dauerhaften
stachel im politischen sein der spd die
begründung für den nicht ausschloss hat
sehr deutlich gemacht wie weit schröder
von einem parteiausschluss entfernt ist
die vorwürfe haben ja nicht einmal für
eine rüge gereicht auch deshalb ist die
strategie der parteispitze jetzt ganz
offensichtlich wenn wir den alt kanzler
schon juristisch nicht ausschließen
können dann zumindest politisch im
grunde leiden ihrer parteien sei es bei
schröder sarrazin maßen oder wagen recht
immer wieder an einem privileg dass
ihnen das grundgesetz zugesteht den in
artikel 21 wird ihre wichtige rolle bei
der politischen willensbildung des
volkes betonte und dazu gehört die
meinungsvielfalt der schutz abweichen
der meinung ist daher besonders hoch
eine reihe von ortsvereinen dürfte jetzt
in die berufung gehen allerdings ohne
große chancen für die parteispitze
bleibt am ende vielleicht nur eine alte
krisenstrategie die da lautet nicht mal
ignorieren danke für die einschätzung
nach berlin theo koll
bei corona ist auch nach über zwei
jahren noch vieles unklar sich
widersprechende experten eine nicht
belastbare incidents lage weil viele
infizierte sich nicht mehr offiziell
testen lassen und auch das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz ist umstritten
bei einer möglichen nächsten corona
welle im herbst und winter stehen
krankenhäuser und impfzentren besonders
im fokus ein überblick von julia
schröter
viele spritzen müssen sie im impfzentrum
in mainz im moment nicht aufziehen nur
etwa 100 am tag für den herbst rechnen
sie hier wieder mit mehr impfungen denn
in einigen wochen werden die neuen
angepassten impfstoffe zugelassen
über den genauen zeitpunkt entscheidet
die europäische arzneimittelagentur das
vakzin von beyond etwa basiert auf der
omicron variante baa1 und dem
ursprünglichen wildtyp die kombination
soll besseren schutz bieten das heißt
aber nicht dass jetzt jeder auf den
neuen impfstoff warten sollte das war
ein zeitfenster entstehen indem man
ungeimpft ist ungelöst ist das kann ich
niemandem empfehlen wer jetzt dran ist
für die zweite dritte oder vierte
impfung der sollte jetzt kommen und
diesen guten aktuellen impfstoff nutzen
wer unsicher ist ob er jetzt dran ist
sollte mit seinem hausarzt sprechen auf
vielen intensivstationen wie hier in
kaiserslautern ist corona derzeit kein
so großes problem
doch auch ohne corona sind sich hier am
limit pflegemangel ärztemangel
investitionsstau all das sei kaum noch
zu bewältigen
letztendlich befinden wir uns und das
müssen wir nicht beschönigen in einer
maximalen versorgungslücke in einem
gesundheitspolitischen tsunami den
können wir nicht mehr wegdiskutieren
viele corona fälle im herbst wären dann
noch ein problem mehr darum hoffen sie
dass es nicht zu schlimm wird und aus
expertensicht spricht einiges dafür
denn ein großer teil der bevölkerung hat
inzwischen durch impfungen und
infektionen einen immunschutz
im supermarkt im restaurant oder an der
tankstelle vieles wird teurer und wir
merken es jeden tag also heißt es geld
zusammenhalten weswegen auch weniger
gekauft wird zum beispiel im
einzelhandel im juni wurden dort 8,8
prozent weniger umgesetzt als noch im
letzten jahr der größte einbruch in fast
drei jahrzehnten bei bekleidung lag das
minus sogar bei über zehn prozent der
online handel verliert noch mehr und
eine branche ist gerade besonders
betroffen mehr von dominik müller russe
übermorgen beginnt in nordrhein
westfalen die schule eigentlich sollte
im düsseldorfer kindermöbel geschäft von
klaus peter maiwald jede menge los sein
doch kaum ein kunde verirrt sich in
diesen tagen zu seinen schreibtischen
und hochbetten um mehr als die hälfte
ist sein umsatz eingebrochen und in
anderen möbelgeschäften zieht es ähnlich
aus die lage ist schon ernst geworden
also ich habe kollegen mit denen ich
auch in verbindung stehe und da ist es
eben so dass auch personal eingespart
wird mittlerweile ich habe jetzt auch
personal einsparen müssen und das sind
eben so sachen an die habe ich natürlich
noch nie gedacht nicht nur möbel auch
kleider und accessoires vieles was man
jetzt nicht unbedingt neu braucht bleibt
in den regalen
wochen in deutschland wirklich im keller
ist und zwar noch schlimmer als in der
anfangszeit
bisher nicht erlebt sondern es gibt eine
große verunsicherung so dass wir
natürlich eine außerordentlich
schwierige situation gerade auch in den
innenstädten und im gesamten
einzelhandel haben mit aktionen die
straßenfesten und verkaufsoffenen
sonntagen versucht der handel menschen
in die städte und geschäfte zu locken
doch das geld sitzt einfach nicht locker
[Musik]
er nehme auch hier vor allem die
gratisangebote waren wir machen auch im
haushaltsplan
schauen wir auf jeden fall dass wir was
zurücklegen und wir jetzt für den
kommenden winter erst kroner nun die
energiepreise die händler sehnen sich
wieder nach normalen zeiten
immerhin die gasspeicher in deutschland
konnten letzte woche weiter zügig
befüllt werden nach neuesten daten liegt
der füllstand bei fast 72 prozent
entwarnung bedeutet das laut
wirtschaftsministerium aber nicht und
weil das gas im winter knapp werden
könnte setzen viele auf strom als
alternative und 600.000 elektrische
heizlüfter wurden allein im ersten
halbjahr verkauft knapp 35 prozent mehr
als im vorjahreszeitraum
aber heizen mit strom im dauergebrauch
das ist teuer eine beispielrechnung ein
üblicher heizlüfter hat eine leistung
von 2000 watt heizt man damit zehn
stunden täglich kommen rund 220 euro im
monat zusammen für einen einzigen lüfter
außerdem warnen experten vor einer
überlastung der stromnetze
isabel de la vega
heizlüfter strahler und radiatoren
solche geräte gehen wie geschnitten brot
auch hier in diesem mainzer baumarkt wer
eine gasheizung hat möchte für
lieferengpässe gewappnet sein die kunden
auch wirklich auch größere mengen für
ganze häuser oder ganze wohnungen so
dass in jedem raum extra gerät steht
also 678 es kein problem
zum problem wird es aber hier bei den
stromnetzen peter lautz ist chef des
wiesbadener netzbetriebs und warnt eine
überlastung des stromnetzes durch
massenhaft zusätzlich eingeschaltete
heizgeräte sei eine realistische gefahr
es könnte zu einem blackout kommen
konkret heißt das in den haushalten
würde der strom ausfallen das bedeutet
aber auch dass in der region
möglicherweise die infrastruktur nicht
mehr wirklich funktioniert die
kassensysteme funktionieren nicht mehr
die ampelanlagen funktionieren nicht
mehr straßenbeleuchtung geht aus die
dauer eines solchen blackout hänge von
den verbrauchern ab sie stecken ihr geld
ein sie haben stromausfall und sie
lassen es eingesteckt sie schalten das
nicht aus und sie ziehen den stecker
nicht aus der steckdose das heißt wenn
wir versuchen das netz wieder
einzuschalten geraten wir direkt nach
dem einschalten in die gleiche überlasst
situation und unsere schutzeinrichtungen
würden wiederum die leitungen abschalten
die meisten heizgeräte brauchen mit bis
zu 2.000 watt sehr viel strom manche
verbraucher haben das durchaus im blick
erstens ist strom heizen das teuerste
was man so machen kann ich habe keine
sorge dass ich für ihre dann ziehe ich
mich etwas wärmer heizgeräte sind eine
problematische alternative wenn das gas
im winter knapper wird
nach dem rücktritt von patricia
schlesinger als intendantin des
rundfunks berlin brandenburg vor den
medien experten und politiker dass die
vorwürfe gegen schlesinger aufgeklärt
werden es geht dabei um mögliche
vorteilsnahme und untreue
inzwischen ermittelt die berliner
staatsanwaltschaft schlesinger hatte
gestern erklärt die persönlichen
angriffe hätten ein ausmaß angenommen
dass es ihr unmöglich mache das amt
weiter auszuüben christhard läpple
das gibt es nicht alle tage
rbb-intendantin patricia schlesinger
tritt zurück und alle parteien in
potsdam begrüßen den schritt der
brandenburgische spd
fraktionsvorsitzende keller bringt die
stimmung auf den punkt das ist das
sammelsurium der vorwürfe der hier einen
eindruck erwecken lässt als würden die
gelder der gebührenzahler nicht
ordnungsgemäß für das programm
eingesetzt oder für die bezahlung der
freien und festen mitarbeiter sondern
hier womöglich für die prunksucht einer
intendantin
die liste der vorwürfe wurde immer
länger wie vetternwirtschaft
vorteilsnahme und verschwendung es geht
um die erhöhung ihres jahresgehaltes
ihre dienstwagen teure neubau projekte
und fragwürdige beraterverträge wovon
selbst ihr mann profitiert haben soll
schließlich konnte die vorwürfe nicht
entkräften und gegenüber den
mitarbeitern erklärte sie ihren
rücktritt so
aktuell steht nicht mehr die
journalistische und publizistische
leistungen des senders im vordergrund
sondern es geht nur um mögliche und
angebliche verfehlungen der intendantin
das bedaure ich sehr und ich
entschuldige mich bei den beschäftigten
des rbb für diese entwicklung diese
entschuldigung reicht der empörten
belegschaft nicht aus es wurde mit
keinem satz
eingeräumt wie leicht dinge falsch
entschieden zu haben sondern frau
schlesinger sieht sich nach wie vor nur
als abfall während der rundfunkrat
hinter verschlossenen türen tagt auch
der journalisten verband heftige kritik
wichtigste ist jetzt dass wirklich
umfassende transparenz kommt dass
aufgeklärt wird nur weil die intendantin
jetzt zurückgetreten ist darf sie sich
auch nicht davon stehe die
staatsanwaltschaft ermittelt wegen des
anfangsverdachts der untreue und
vorteilsnahme und der rbb sucht eine
neue leitung
weiter mit dem sport fußball bundesliga
christian der erste fc köln gewinnt und
ist trotzdem sauer ja man fühlt sich
wahrlich überrumpelt der erste fc köln
verbuchte aber auch ohne anthony modeste
der heute zum medizincheck bei borussia
dortmund musste einen wichtigen
auftakterfolg gegen aufsteiger schalke
04 der sieg schmälert aber nicht den
frust wegen des plötzlichen wechsel des
torjägers
gewonnen und doch nicht glücklich fc
trainer baumgart verärgert weil der
abschied seines trägers modell ist kurz
vor dem spiel durchgesickert war und er
seinen stürmer aus dem kader nehmen
musste das kotzt mich an nicht das erste
mal dass etwas rauskommt vier stunden
vor dem spiel kommen wir dadurch in eine
schwierige situation nicht nur das
wechseltheater sorgt für wirbel auch der
schiedsrichter und video assistent
schalke sauer weil das tor von salazar
nachträglich wegen abseits aberkannt
wird und der vr dann auch noch dafür
sorgt dass es eine umstrittene rote
karte für drexler gibt der fc hat in
überzahl leichtes spiel für die
entscheidung sorgt lubicz zum 3
1-endstand köln siegt auch ohne modell
ist und schalke startet mit schiri frust
in die saison und
die highlights aller bundesligaspieler
finden sie auf zdf heute.de und in der
zdf- heute- app zu gold reichte es
diesmal nicht aber mit bronze hat die
neu formierte deutsche dressur equipe
bei den rad weltmeisterschaften im
dänischen herning das wichtigste ziel
erreicht olympia qualifikation für paris
die beste aus dem deutschen quartett war
isabell werth auf quantas ein hengst auf
dem sie zuvor noch keinen großen
wettbewerb bestritten hat
in den letzten 56 jahren passierte es
nur drei mal dass deutschland kein wm
gold holte
[Applaus]
allerdings nahmen drei der vier
deutschen reiter zum ersten mal
überhaupt an einem drittel championat
teil wie zb frederik wanderes auf youth
briten
apropos dritten platz zwei ging an
großbritannien obwohl gareth hughes
corona infiziert damit start ging
diesmal mit dem veranstalter
abgesprochen weniger dann schon die
umarmungen ohne maske der wm titel
gingen nach dänemark
am mittwoch beginnen auch die
springreiter dankeschön christin zum
wetter so viel ändern tut sich
eigentlich wenig mehr gleich von stan
terry 21 45 ist die zeit fürs heute
sonne heute mit marietta slomka das war
es für den montag schönen abend schön
dank und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
schokolade und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter wir schauen auf den juli zurück
das sind die neuesten daten des
kopernikus programms und sie sehen über
weiten teilen europas war es zu warm
kein wunder eine hitzewelle nach der
anderen kam bis zu uns sogar und bei uns
in deutschland wo rund 40 grad erreicht
aber in england vor allem ebenfalls 40
grad und diese temperatur gab es bis
dato noch nie dort in frankreich
herrscht eine extreme dürre eine rekord
dürre wie sie bisher noch nicht gegeben
hat und dort muss wasser rationiert
werden ja wasser kommt nicht dazu wir
haben es weiterhin mit einem
umfangreichen hoch zu tun das dehnt sich
aus und in der nacht bleibt es trocken
wenige wolken nach süden und südwesten
hin ja und die temperaturen dazu mit 9
grad im vogtland recht kühle auch nach
südosten hin 16 grad im
rhein-main-gebiet morgen viel
sonnenschein weiterhin zu trocken ja und
im norden kompaktere wolken aber auch da
fällt nichts raus bei temperaturen von
32 grad im südwesten deutschlands und 21
grad richtung nordsee die nächsten tage
weiterhin trocken und heiß temperaturen
bis 34 grad ein schöner abend